you
hi Bruins Jerry we had a very rare
matchup in chess in the 77th tata steel
chess tournament 2015 to current world
champions competing on the white end the
current world chess champion in world
number one Magnus Carlsen against the
current Women's World Chess Champion and
world number seventy if an HOH let's
have a look at it we had Magnus opening
up with e4 this game here turned out to
be quite the positional struggle he fan
replying with the Sicilian we get to see
an open Sicilian with d4 after E 5 and D
6 we have more specifically the
Kalashnikov variation with a now c4 it's
at this stage we can already identify a
couple key squares weak squares in the
position d4 is weak for white d5 for
black weak because neither sides pawns
can now control those squares following
up we have Bishop e7 there's a reason to
delay Knight f6 that'll be revealed
shortly but first more development
Knight c3 black gives that Knight a kick
Bishop e6 and 90 night to see to do
similar watching over those weekend
squares and now Bishop g5 welcoming a
dark square Bishop exchange a bad Bishop
for a good Bishop and this is a good
idea not only for not only related to
bad bishop good bishop exchange but also
related to white having more space
seeing some peace exchanging have it
having a minor piece exchange as a
welcome site for black these guys here a
bit cramping to the black position not
allowing any pawn breaks so easily so we
have Bishop to e2 avoiding this exchange
with the Knight e3 well he had a job to
watch over d4 really can't avoid that
exchange and you really can try and win
upon like this because at the end of the
day your queen is going to be won if you
move the Queen you're getting mated so
just have to allow that exchange
there's some time invested with that but
again I think it's a good exchange I
think it's time well spent
you'll notice that Bishop took what
three moves to capture piece that moved
not at all but in the end I think it is
worthwhile to do so so getting on with
more development Knight f6 both sides
Castle Queen d2 it's getting all pieces
work in Queen b6 you could take this
pawn but you'll drop B till that's not
such a healthy exchange he's probably
the least healthy black pawn and he's
very important for white the central
pawn for the White Queen side majority
so instead it's getting the last piece
involved and black gets rook F to d8 in
this pond cannot be taken because the
Queen would be trapped so lets rook F D
8 B 3 C 4 is now defended via pond so
this Bishop can do some other things
both sides get a flight square in the
least committal flight square not making
any permanent weaknesses with those
moves and following up we have Queen a7
this is freeing up maybe at some stage
b5 but that's very difficult to get in
with a pawn Knight and Bishop they're
controlling it we have Bishop f3 now and
so this is paving the way for a knight
hop into the center doing so right away
would drop efore I take c4 is there so
Bishop f3 this is now a possibility and
black anticipates this with 97 getting
in a position essentially to be able to
capture on that square with the bishop
and not have to react to some threat on
the night on that c6 square so he gets
out of harm's way white never goes in
for it though instead plays Knight e3
you see what just happened there there's
a certain tension in this current
position right here on that d4 square
these guys are essentially negating one
another they're boxing each other out
there fighting for that d4 square as
soon as 97 is there well this Knight now
has
a bit more freedom to maybe do other
things 93 this hop this happens quite a
bit not in this game just generally
speaking in chess when there's a certain
tension between pieces when they're
fighting for particular squares if one
goes elsewhere well maybe the other can
go elsewhere and we see that take shape
on this move 18 so black tries to get
back to it knight c6 dropping into that
d4 square white has some other things in
mind looking to eliminate this Bishop if
Bishop takes Bishop well now this starts
to become all the more appealing
dropping into that week in d5 square
black has another thing in mind allowing
Bishop takes Bishop and now recapturing
with the pond doubled pawns well this is
a very valuable pawn watching over d5
and now this Knight needs to be dealt
with it's the one piece in the white
position that needs to be addressed so
the knight drops back to c2 and we have
this particular night exchange this was
an interesting moment the remaining
pieces here these four pieces they
there's a lot of maneuvering that goes
on from here on out and I wonder if it
would have been better to keep yet
another piece on board and instead of
capturing the knight to play back to c6
and claim that this Knight is better
placed than the one on c2 still you know
if he if he used to go elsewhere he's
very quick to drop right back into that
d4 square it's it's a tough call I'm not
completely sure about it but my general
feel for it is to drop back to c6 and
just keep this possibility available one
other more technical way to maybe view
it is if we look at the two knights here
the one on c6 is more secure in that
it's defended by upon whereas this night
here on c2 is defended by a piece and
those pieces may want to go elsewhere at
some stage maybe he is
practically vulnerable I'm not
completely sure I don't see that in this
current position but you never know if
the position is to open up at some stage
maybe he's a bit more vulnerable being
uncie to not protected by a pond when
compared to his counterpart on c6 who
has some defense it's just a thought to
keep one more piece on board or not in
the game if an ops for a knight exchange
and we have from here on out a lot of
maneuvering defensive d6 also looking to
maybe build up for a d5 break but that
never happens white isn't allowing that
so easily this is an interesting rook
lift there's already an ID in mind with
swinging the rook over to the G file so
rook d3 and only then is this rook going
to later come over to d2 after Queen c5
Knight a for the Queen has to react and
if this is an idea to come over to this
g3 square it's important with how you
defend this pawn of course there might
be the temptation to play f3 and just
have a pawn watch over upon but that's
going to rule out not only a rip coming
over here but quick access to the Kings
side along this diagonal pawn interferes
with both of those so instead it's four
at least right now rook III defending
the e4 for a second time
b6 a little Knight maneuver here rook
getting active and after Knight see 593
this is stopping Knight here because
Knight takes e5 exploiting the pin on
the d8 rook
so instead Knight a5 this is stopping
Knight B for a move that might be a bit
uncomfortable I'm to just make a passing
move like rook F a knight B 4 hits the
Queen the pawn and unleashes the rook on
d6 so it's a 5 and now this weekend's b5
and so the knight is going to try to
make use of that square you have first
night b2 you can try Knight a4 to c3 or
even Knight d1 to c3 Knight C five stops
Knight a four but the knight goes in the
other direction repositioning getting
into that c3 square black is putting
pressure with that last move on f2 to
wreak a fate it's defended with Queen
the e1 rook is there to defend it comes
back it's difficult to suggest something
for black here white is slowly making
some progress here what's happening here
is a with this is a little Knight dance
or Knight maneuver here is that he's
going to be really well placed soon on
the c3 square now that this pawn is more
secured with a minor piece in a rook
that means the Queen is now freed up to
do some other things black gets over
there to secure d6 Queen to d1 again
these pawn breaks in the position are
all under control
Queen d1 arriving back at our home
square is now looking to jet out to that
h5 Square 98-96 Queen h5 Knight c7 rook
g3 and we're going to slowly have the
doubling on the G file that's what white
is preparing again none of this would be
possible if this pawn was on that f3
Square trying to defend efore earlier he
needed this square open the f3 Square
open for all of these heavy pieces to
try and stir up some trouble against the
black King you'll notice after rook to
g3 this was a threat King h8 gets out of
that Queen takes h6 move rook on d2 d3
rook d7 we have the doubling happening
right here rook d7 another reposition
with the knight he's now trying to inch
closer towards the black king
maybe g4 and then crashing through on h6
rook f7 you have to be very careful here
it's a very aggressive pieces here on
the white side but
if you're not careful just having a
couple peace exchanges can turn the
tables a bit the follow up here is
Queenie - about how natural would it be
to just simply want or drop your nitrite
into e3 that was the intention wasn't it
you go to d1 why is white not following
through with an immediate night to e3
well the reason is because of H rook to
f6
welcome welcoming some exchanges here
you can't take on f6 because you're
dropping the Queen and so this is going
to make some this is going to force some
exchanges and black will have no
problems defending the king I mean what
are you what are you going to do here
Queen G for rook takes Queen takes Queen
takes this rook is a bit clumsy right
he's a bit out of play the the black
king is much quicker to contribute to
control in the center and maybe this is
now not going to be so long off he's
misplaced if there's too many peace
exchanges so white anticipates this move
and that's why we don't have 93 but
rather a queen move Queen to e2 getting
out of that rook F for keeping pressure
on or entering the white position and
keeping pressure on e4 maybe not
allowing this move so easily now right
interfering with the Queen's defense so
it's Queen III throwing a punch at b6 b5
Knight b2 is there to defend this would
be a very welcome sight to capture like
this you could be recapturing with the
knight or even the pond here the knight
would really like to get to this d3
Square and kick the rook out of there
and that is the main intention here
night b2 looks to get into this d3
Square hits the rook puts pressure on
this pond there's even ideas of
undermining the black center with c5
having a knight on d3 is quite powerful
so black doubles hitting at f2 this
could be ignored
c5 now undermines this black center this
is starting to open up and white is the
side who is benefitting having a better
place tonight he's very clumsy on c7 and
this is a rook that has a great deal of
depth pressure on this sixth rank
pressure on that h6 square more
specifically there's some tricks not
long off here Queen c5 if you're
capturing this pawn Knight d6 or Knight
d3 is a killer just hitting everything
this is going to crumble fast
so instead Queen c6 Knight D 3 and B 4
so this rook could be taken some time
was spent on this about about 8 minutes
was spent you could capture this rook at
this point here but instead white goes
for something else Queen to e2 not
capturing that rook if you capture the
rook right away there is this fork but
you do have the move Queen f3 and so if
pawn takes you're getting the rook right
back but I don't know that this is a
good option here have Queen takes e5 and
then rook here you could even do moves
like this if there's some exchanges
again these rooks if enough material is
exchanged one of the rooks can find
themselves just out of play
there'll be no more attack against the
King in the attention will turn in a
different section of the board on the
Queen side just to emphasize one point
here for your exchange in Queens usually
a good idea when you're up material how
do you stop that pun so we're not going
in for this exchange first is Queen e2
now maybe this is on rip to h4 this is
stopping the Queen from entering the h5
at allowing this Queen h5 move there
could be some serious issue if that's
played just making a move here such as
Knight b5 Queen here is already
threatening some stuff on this h6 square
so rook h4 is interfering with this
following up work G for rook takes Queen
takes Queen is now very active this rook
is tethered to the defense of g7 this
pawn could never move and white is very
close to just snipping that pawn and
then crashing through on d6 but need
some more pressure on e5 before pulling
the trigger on that capture King to g8
Queen age 5 and after Knight b5 we have
rook g4 so this is getting out of the
way of some possibility for an ie to
fork against the rook and the King
following up we have Knight c3 Queen
takes h6 is there a better defense
against this right here not really if
you're getting out of the pin with King
to f8 this is going to collapse by way
of C takes D Knight takes D and well
this point is collapsing right here
doesn't matter how you how you look at
it this Knight is going to be dropping
in here not just winning upon but
improving his position and doing so with
tempo not really a great defense here of
Queen takes h6 so we have Knight c3
clean takes H Knight takes e
this rook isn't a pin Knight takes e5 is
on board exploiting the pin against the
Queen and what's tried is Knight F to
Knight takes e5 and one last try Knight
takes h3 but after King h2 this is game
over it's at this point that black
resigns the only thing that white needed
to watch out for is this capture here or
I should say capturing the knight will
allow Queen take C and there's just a
this is just a direction not to go in at
all white king is in big trouble
actually so just one column move here to
finish up King h2 and there's no defense
here again you can't take the knight
although that's the top suggestion by
the computer to take the knight and then
give up the Queen
doing something other than that such as
queen bee seven to defend the rook is
already running into a mate and six
starting with Knight g6 looking for this
stuff here and if the back rank is now
defended don't forget about this either
so there's just not going to be a good
solution at this point and again after
King age 2 it's at that point that black
resigns so a very interesting game a
unique game for sure to have two world
champions going at it quite the
positional struggle out of the open
Sicilian the Kalashnikov variation a
reason to not go with that quick Knight
f6 getting the bad bishop for good
Bishop exchange some time invested with
that but time well-spent especially
since we had such a manoeuvring game
such a fairly closed position time not
such a great element and this tension
here it's important detail sometimes
when one Knight moves here if there's
certain tension between pieces when one
Knight moves maybe the other one's going
to be a bit more optimistic maybe he has
different ideas in mind maybe he could
do some other things if I if your
opponent's night is going elsewhere a
lot of maneuvering this one d5 was
repaired the decision to capture the
knight or not I'm not so sure feel free
to share some feedback on this
particular exchange I can't be
completely sure but maybe got something
from some of those thoughts that I
shared there and eventually not playing
f6 that was an interesting point here
not defending like so as soon as the
knight arrived on that c3 square for
white now we started to have these major
pieces drift over towards that black
King and you have to be careful with
your attack Queen e2 avoids too many
exchanges and eventually this knight on
d3 became intolerable too much pressure
the undermining of the black center and
this is where it's really starting to
collapse the white knight was certainly
the more dominant one and finally
avoiding one last trick
King h2 and that's going to seal the
deal there so a very interesting game I
hope you enjoyed it and as always I hope
you got something on this video take
care bye